okay we've been talking about these sort
of like for meta issues in American
politics for a while now
one of those is climate change climate
change if we don't deal with it it
impacts everything else that we care
about if your cities underwater it's
hard to be an activist for education
policy is the way I like to sort of
apply a metaphor or an example to it net
neutrality and Internet freedom is
another meta issue we learn about most
of what's going on in the world through
the news media and through the internet
and through websites and from news
stations that are so impacted by net
neutrality and Internet freedom so
that's another meta issue that affects a
lot of what we care about our electoral
system is a third the fact that we have
an electoral college and everything that
connects to that including voter
suppression voter ID but the way votes
are counted the way primaries are
handled all of that stuff so the
electoral system would be like meta
issue number three and then you've got
campaign finance which rounds out the
list the way politics is financed in the
United States a big part of campaign
finance is Citizens United now it's not
the only part it's not the only reason
why we have the system of campaign
finance that we have today but it is a
big part of it and Democratic
congressman Adam Schiff has now
introduced a constitutional amendment to
overturn citizens united citizens united
is the 2010 Supreme Court decision that
did away with corporate campaign
spending restrictions and if this
constitutional amendment were ratified
it would allow limits to be put back in
place by Congress and by states on the
contributions that companies can make
and it would let States decide if for
example they want to make public
financing of Elections the law of the
land so this is huge
it's great news it's the right thing we
should support it but there are caveats
caveat number one is this is going
nowhere for as long as Republicans
control the Senate and for as long as
Republican a Republican is in the White
House that's number one but it's still
good to get this going and I support
Adam Schiff doing it because we've been
talking about a constitutional amendment
for a long time at the same time it's
really important to understand and this
is a great opportunity to do it that
there are many other things we can do to
deal with the money in politics status
quo which is a disaster in the United
States that are separate from the repeal
of citizens united number one we can
change our voting system in ways that
would be a huge step in the right
direction some of the specifics about
how that can be done we've talked about
on the show already the point is that's
totally separate from citizens united
and it could lead to significant
improvements in the sort of election
status quo of the United States of
America number two we could get rid of
the electoral college the national
popular vote interstate compact is about
70 percent of the way to achieving 270
electoral votes which would allow with
no change to the Constitution a de facto
national popular vote that's something
else we can continue working on number
three gerrymandering yes
gerrymandering is connected to money in
politics but gerrymandering is also
connected to many other things including
the census which is upcoming in 2020 and
in general doing redistricting with a
nonpartisan or bipartisan Commission's
sometimes employing particular
mathematical algorithms rather than the
whimsy of individual partisan lawmakers
there's a lot that can be done with
gerrymandering that doesn't require
repealing citizens united dealing with
voter suppression tactics this includes
everything from voter ID limiting
limiting early voting reducing the
number of polling places on and on and
on we've talked about all of those
things yes a lot of that connects to
citizens united and how politics is
financed but we can also accomplish a
lot independently on that but all of
this is really to build on fixing money
in politics it's not instead of fixing
money in politics so we do need to get
rid of
United but it's also really important to
understand that in the nine years and
citizens united became the law of the
land it has opened the door to a lot of
other incremental changes citizens
united in and of itself is not the
change that needs to be undone it's a
big change that needs to be undone
but it has opened the door to a lot of
little changes getting rid of
restrictions on what's called Express
advocacy allowing electioneering by more
organizations which in and of itself led
to the creation of many super PACs and
lots of other things
so obviously citizens united allowed a
lot of these other things to take place
but what we need to not forget is that
even if we were to overturn citizens
united by whatever means it's ultimately
overturned if it ever is
you still need to undo a lot of that
other stuff that came from the Citizens
United ruling and that's a major uphill
battle it's worth doing it's not
impossible but understand that even the
Citizens United repeal is one step of
probably hundreds just in that pillar of
the broader total reforms that were
advocating for so good for Adam Schiff
this is the right thing we should push
for it we should support it but let's
not overstate its importance and most
importantly let's remember that there
are you know like six or seven other
areas that we can be working on right
now simultaneously well we push for
getting the Senate back and getting the
White House back which will at least
make the path to repealing Citizens
United easier the Supreme Court that
Donald Trump has appointed two justices
to will be an impediment even if
Democrats do take over the Senate in the
White House but that'll be a problem
that'll be a bridge we cross when we
come to it there are way more things
that we can be working on simultaneously
related to fixing elections in American
politics let me know what you think
about this the David Pakman show
Instagram page at David Pakman show has
a post about this while you're there
follow me on Instagram as well at David
Pakman if you love learning new things
you probably want to check this out the
day
Pakman show today's sponsored by
Skillshare and we're giving you two
entire months of free access to
Skillshare when you click the link
underneath this video Skillshare is a
vibrant online learning community
offering more than 25,000 video classes
on just about anything you can think of
get better at playing an instrument
learn to use Photoshop how to edit
videos they have classes on drawing
painting business cooking nutrition
personal productivity and I'm not even
really scratching the surface I recently
took a great class on introductory
watercolour painting I'm still not good
but I am learning and you can access the
entire library of fun easy-to-use online
courses for free for two months by using
the link underneath this video two
months of learning something that's
totally new to you something you want to
get better at something you already love
or you can get ahead in your career by
learning new skills that will help you
at your job I've gotten a ton out of it
Pat has taken some courses that he's
found really valuable and I think you'll
love it to get started for free by
clicking the link under this video